[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
delighted to finally get you on it's
been years in the making yeah there's a
lot to catch up on I I heard you for too
long it's all good I forgive you I mean
you've given us an interview at the best
possible
for the moment welcome back to the truth
already podcast today's guest is the
second of my friends to be fighting
Floyd Mayweather
[__] weird life full of the minute uh
deji thanks for coming on no thank you
for having me oh man what a life really
weird being you right now like you were
basically a bit of a laughingstock for
this guy who couldn't win a fight for
love no money and and watching you there
was times where I was like God I give up
on this guy yeah I just don't know if
he's ever gonna come good then the last
fight
I've never been proven more wrong about
someone in that in in terms of the box
and sense like you destroyed it was
amazing and fousey is no like he's no
pushover he's a tough kid he came in in
shape probably the best shape we've seen
any YouTube boxer in yeah and you just
walk through them with skill and then
Floyd Mayweather how do we go from that
to that what tell me the process of the
phone call like the reach out what
happened so I actually have to you know
like give credit to believe it or not
Ryan Taylor wow yeah so Ryan Taylor's
the one who called me being like do you
want to fight Floyd and I was like okay
how the [__] does Ryan tell us no Ryan
has he's got connections I know yeah
he's connected so yeah honestly so um
that's how it happened he just messaged
me being like no he called me being like
you want to fight Floyd I was like yeah
of course I was like all right cool yeah
well I've already sorted it out because
I knew you're gonna say yes so yeah now
I'm fine so he was the connect yeah yeah
honestly did you see him and slim on the
call yeah I saw their um their uh
that was a that was amazing yeah I'm
weirdly hyped for that fight as well
like I because there's a backstory and
they have that brawl and I feel like
that should be Main Event though like no
no offense yeah but I don't know who the
guy is who Jessica obviously we've heard
of those two uh and Slim's on the up
right now yeah we'll talk about that
later your fight was there any point
where you were like
I might get my ass kicked in like I'm
not sure about this when I signed to
fight fousey I was scared but then
there's someone who helped me throughout
my whole Camp I've said his name many
times Shane yeah you set him in your
post-match fight interview with me yeah
so Shane he if it wasn't for Shane
I don't think I would have won my fight
against fousey so what's your
relationship with this guy so I met
Shane back in year seven wow yeah okay
so literally the moment we met we like
became friends it was it was weird and
now he's just been friends ever since so
he's the one who said I'm tired of
seeing you lose because he's a chef so
so he said I'm gonna do your Macros I'm
gonna cook all your food I'm gonna help
you out so he came to all my training
sessions he just
was he was there for me through
everything when we first started I had
no snc coach
and uh I was too afraid to approach Leon
because I knew Leon didn't rape me and
also Leon in Amanda
because your truck record is terrible in
regards to your Fitness exactly and
Leon's not someone who takes anything
lightly yeah exactly so uh he was the
one saying you know what just contact
him just contact him remember I was just
too afraid so then so he took my phone
and messaged JJ instead and then JJ
contacted Leon for me and then that's
how I uh got in contact with Leon Leon
put me through a very grueling session
and that's what really you know spurred
you on yeah yeah I must admit that was
watching that was the moment when in the
run-up I heard you were with Leon I was
like oh
that's an X Factor that I didn't see
coming because it was to me it was like
I I know you're about a boxer than Foods
yeah I just didn't have faith in you to
be in shape on the night yeah exactly
and obviously with Leon behind you
that's a leon if you want chaos you got
a leon
this man has got a great record with
YouTube boxes
um halfway through the camp
move this fousey cap no no you know what
no talking back uh to the signing thing
yeah so if it wasn't for Shane
I wouldn't have signed the the dotted
line because with fousey yeah because I
was petrified everyone was saying fousey
he's got power uh if you get tags you'll
get knocked out this that blah blah blah
and everything and one of my fears was
getting knocked out right but now I
don't care like if because of Leon and
Shane I I go in then I just go in for
the kill
during that fight there was a moment
where I was ringside obviously I'm
commentating and I looked at you
bringing him on come on come on and I'm
like wow wow because you weren't doing
this to nobody enthusi is a a solid
competitor I'm gonna give it his all he
wasn't to be fair you know if you look
at the guy who uh JJ fought first the
guy who's running away doing ballerina
you know
inviting him on and that level of
confidence comes from that hard work
doesn't it literally yeah so um yeah so
I owe it to Shane and Leon as well as
daily of course of course but uh Shane
and Leon helped me mentally like halfway
through the camp like I was saying I
would I would go into spars and I and I
wouldn't be throwing do you know how I
was with Alex I wouldn't be throwing any
punches it was literally the exact same
wow so um and that was because you were
scared of getting hurt yeah literally
but I was getting hurt more because it
wasn't well yeah because you're not
giving them a reason to keep offer you
yeah yeah literally so then Leon came to
my house and uh then I was like telling
Leon yeah the spars were fine they said
whatever me not knowing that Shane's
recording the Spurs
so I'm telling Leon yeah the spars went
fine it was sick this that blah blah
blah and then Shane shows Lee on the
spots like that deji's terrible this
that whatever and then Leon's like
what's going on why aren't you throwing
any punches if you don't start throwing
punches I'm not gonna I'm not gonna be
there in your corner anymore I'm not
doing this I'm not doing that yeah this
is halfway through uh the camp and
everything wow yeah this is like a a
moment of worry then yeah or circling
you exactly you respect but then
we started talking for like three hours
straight so Leon obviously you know he's
found out yeah I'm not throwing any
punches but then he's trying to like
understand me why I'm not throwing
punches and everything so he um he kinda
he puts it in a way like a better like
perspective for me because I love Tekken
right so I've never seen that coming
okay yeah so I love taking like it so he
was telling me to put it in the same
perspective as like as like Tekken
because in Tekken it's all Frame data
isn't it so uh with boxing it's like
essentially it's the same if they throw
a jab like uh I can punish it if this
that whatever you know what I mean so oh
yes yeah so when someone throws at you
your brain is now understanding this in
a different way exactly this is an
opportunity for me to punish you exactly
because I know if you do X I do y there
you go then you have the answer for it
exactly that's very smart of Leon I've
got a lot of credit for trying to yeah
to speak it in a language like you'll
digestive person that's that's what a
great coach does yeah and he's done that
with
um obviously Gibb yeah I remember him
having his hair pulling out his hair
watching Gibb sparring getting angry and
you know how to say when he gets angry
and he starts saying he shouts at you
like your own dad you know I've seen him
do that with Gibb and you know credit to
Leon I didn't say like he's made a real
impact on so many young Lads life like
that yeah honestly exactly it's not it's
not just boxing it's everything yeah so
like my mentor coming into anything is
just different and that was why when I
was in the rig with you afterwards I
said you look like a different person
and the penny had dropped hadn't yeah
why you know you know when you're a lion
to him how did that make you feel when
you're lying to Leon because Leon's
putting his time and energy into you and
he could be doing other things and
you're lying to him did how was that for
you so I didn't want to be honest
because I didn't want to disappoint him
because I was giving him my all during
these sessions so I didn't want him to
to kind of like Backtrack on me if that
makes sense so that's why I chose to lie
which obviously wasn't the best choice
but that's why I'm like so thankful to
Shane being honest but in terms of Floyd
right okay so you get off the phone yeah
you have a greater fight Floyd yeah but
then you have to sit there and go holy
[__] so who do you tell first what are
you thinking at that point do you ring
someone or what are you doing first
person I told was Shane so before I even
signed anything I called Shane and I was
like she said I was telling I'm scared
like yeah I'm about to be scared again
and then James just like sign it just
sign it stop being a [__] just sign it
literally and then I was like okay cool
and then I signed it because um
I I know when I know that Shane's got my
back then I'm like cool how many Floyd
fights have you seen do you think how
many fluid fights have I seen like full
fights full fights I saw the the Manny
Pacquiao fight obviously the Conor
McGregor fight I've seen his exhibitions
like a handful really literally so
you're getting in there with someone
who's almost like a mythical like
doesn't even feel like a real person
literally probably because his Legend is
so big it you know what you said before
you were scared how were you feeling now
as now it's been announced now I'm going
for the kill really but honestly going
for the kill obviously I'm gonna assume
my respects and everything but like uh
in there yeah but I'm coming there to
fight I'm not I'm not going there to uh
to you know essentially survive I'm
going in there to do your best exactly
because this is a once in a lifetime
opportunity I'm never gonna get this
again so well yeah you never know
there's a tricky there's a tricky one
because I watched Daily's video who's
your boxing coach you're talking about
you know why a lot of people have said
why did you take this you know he's he
doesn't need to go in there and get
beaten up by Floyd and yada yada and and
there's two schools of thought there's
going there yeah possibly get beaten up
badly by Floyd Mayweather but it's Floyd
maywether so there's no shame in it
oh don't do it and live to probably
regret ever having the opportunity to
share the ring with the greatness
exactly yeah so realistically there's
there's no there's no loss on my side I
get beaten up I I got in there which is
already in itself a bit like a victory
so
it's I I can I do I do well as a win win
I get in there it's a win so
realistically it's just there's no loss
I've got nothing to lose that's what
we're dearly described it my only my
only worry and this has not seen that
this will happen yeah but confidence is
something that you've already said is a
big thing for you yeah so you've built
up this confidence now with fousey Floyd
can take anyone's confidence away within
minutes you know and it hopefully I just
I hope if it doesn't go the way you want
to yeah you you are proud of yourself
because taking this on it's a true test
of a man to get in there with someone
who you know can do what you want yeah
literally so you got balls
and and hopefully you make some good
[__] money out of there yeah how are
you feeling about the cash side of
things is it good or I'm being paid by
the company not by him so I'm definitely
yeah
[__] sake this guy is still trying to
get this money is there really build
this date down the hood that's uh he got
paid the money up from but not the
pay-per-view yeah
[__] you Paula why do you think Floyd is
still fighting people like yourself and
Logan so I believe so there's there no
there's two things so obviously because
he's been doing this since he's young
and he can't just hang up the towel it's
impossible to do let's say if I'm like
I've been playing games since I was
young I can't just stop gaming if that
makes sense I play less games but I
still every now and then I play a game
I'll put up the game of FIFA and then
I'm done and you think that's the same
for him I believe so yeah he just
there's rumors of him having Financial
worries which
seems
the amount of money is made in the in
the game you think not but then
you know get in there with Logan and
yeah as honest he doesn't even know what
a bank is does he because he just keeps
it
well I see my mate a footballer who I
interviewed called Kieran Dyer yeah who
was very close friends with uh Floyd in
his prime said when you went round to
his house yeah there was [__] belts
everywhere money everywhere that he was
just living life like the wildest
[__] right in his prime uh going
back to the Logan Paul fight yeah what
did you think of that at first I didn't
oh I was kind of yeah I didn't think it
was gonna happen but then when they
start doing the face to face then I then
I knew yeah okay this is happening and
uh got your heart yeah yeah Jake really
helped that from actually to be fair you
did yeah yeah Jake did well pissed him
off though yeah Jake's actually come out
with a comment about this fight I don't
know if you've seen his reaction to it I
haven't no he's basically sort of trying
to get Floyd to fight him by saying you
know you you're kind of fighting
nobodies and stuff like that and I don't
know if it was a dis on you specifically
as more of a dis on Floyd saying you
know you're fighting people tarnishing
your legacy when there's bigger fights
out there for you yeah uh seeing that
Floyd is scared to fight him
um what do you make of that
um obviously
I I guess Jake he he just wants to fight
Floyd realistically so we have that how
does it feel like you lost the joke but
now you're in the hot scene you've got
what people want I mean
I'm blessed that's all I can really say
you're like that so and the Logan fight
the actual the actual rounds themselves
Logan starts up strong yeah Floyd comes
on what did you make of the contest
itself obviously it was a complete
mismatch but I'm fed to Floyd he held
his own against someone who's has better
reach heavier like literally everything
the swaying and Logan's favor aside from
the skill yeah yeah there was a lot made
of that fight because afterwards I think
a lot of people a lot of people were
saying
Floyd curried Logan Floyd could have
done what he wanted him with that at any
point he could have ended that fight and
I get like people love Floyd and they
want to believe that he's like a modern
day ninja but in my opinion when I
watched that fight I thought Floyd did
everything he could to hurt Logan but
Logan was such a big guy Logan and fit
as well look could just take it all and
what really proved that for me was when
you looked at the other exhibitions
Floyd has had he's absolutely wrecked
everyone else he's been in there with
and when people say that this is an
exhibition your fight with him yeah I do
think if you look at the exhibitions
Floyd's had he's ruthless and I if I'm
preparing you as a coach of you I would
be saying he ain't going to take it easy
on you so this is it like the fittest
edgy we've ever seen the best edgy we
could possibly make yeah do you agree
with that 100 100 like uh because he's
quite a spiteful he's got that nastiness
in his heart that he enjoys
punishing people yeah no I I I I
understand I I'm the exact same yeah but
I'm sparring someone and I know I've
heard them I'm just like yeah nice oh I
make them well you need that yeah if you
don't have Spike you shouldn't be in
there exactly uh and I think there's a
lot of people there's a lot of nice guys
in the YouTuber boxing like uh fear
Sensei you won't thank me for saying
that but has all the skills but not
necessarily the nastiness too
execute someone in public like that you
know and I just wondered if you were
under any illusion in what you are going
to be facing in flight because when he
gets in there
he's smiling I don't know if you've seen
that in some of his recent he he seems
to really enjoy the watching them Wilt
in front of him slowly but surely and
personally with your fight you don't
have the size of Logan you are gonna
have to be as crafty and clever as
possible when you're in there what what
kind of things has Daly been saying to
you on the run-up to this that's the
thing so I I don't know if I should say
too much because like obviously Floyd is
probably going to watch this obviously
technically I technically you have to
give away game plans but more mental
side of things how are you feeling like
how is he preparing you for that prepare
me I mean so
there's no blueprint to beat Floyd
realistically because
yeah but what I'm mainly focusing on is
my cardio because if my fitness is bad
he's gonna make me look stupid you know
I mean I mean he he had Logan tired in
there yeah yeah and this one's a big fit
guy yeah so that is a big problem and
we're doing eight rounds as well wow
yeah exactly wow
that says that the intent is there to
finish you before the end of that fight
yeah to me anyway yeah yeah so because
his last exhibition was three rounds
wasn't it yeah and he's still got them
over there pretty quick yeah and I mean
like it was in Japan I believe yeah it
was in Japan yeah yeah he's had a few of
those cash in hand jobs with he just
turns up knocks someone out who goes
back to the dressing room [__] off home
uh but this is going to be a bigger
event I mean you guys have got I believe
Tommy Fury is going to be on the card
yeah versus Tyron Woodley that's the
rumor yeah wow yeah I mean that that's a
really exciting mate of fights then I'm
having a press tour as well press
conference in Vegas another one in
London then I think the final one's
going to be in Dubai I want us to get
Floyd on the podcast you know now this
is what made me wonder about his
finances because I I thought you know
I'll ask and I got through through a
friend of a friend I got caught at 10
grand to have him on the podcast I
thought
I don't know what to make of that it
doesn't because if you've got loads of
money why quote me 10 grand and then
like I just think that everything's for
a price with him and maybe that's him
being smart but I didn't pay it
I mean but he's in it's such a
mysterious thing with why he carries on
fighting like this I feel like with
Floyd he uh he goes so
if you go hard he'll go hard if you go
soft he'll go soft and I've noticed that
especially with his last fight in the
exhibition the guy was going harder than
he was like okay I have to go hard you
know I mean so I thought that's how
Floyd is
he doesn't want to get hurt Floyd
doesn't want to get hurt doing these
exhibitions so if you're kind of soft
like taking it like taking your time and
everything you'll do the exact same
stuff and I've noticed that about him as
well because when he thought his friend
Don Moore
yeah and then so Floyd was like okay
time for me to go hard too yeah so you
go soft he'll go softer you go hard
he'll go hard you go harder yeah so I
remember I've got memory of Don Moore
and against the Rope sort of like Jesus
[__] yeah Floyd just in his face like
oh yeah yeah I was like I walk I
remember watching that uh when I knew
you were coming on the show just
thinking of you just thinking like [__]
me your balls getting in there with him
what what what do you think um
when you look at Floyd yeah and he's a
master of the game I mean the thousands
of thousands of hours he's put into this
it's it's unmatched even
um
what do you think your take away from
that whole experience is going to end up
being
I'm gonna see all these like YouTube
books essentially yeah YouTube boxes
but realistically we are now all proper
Fighters I I hate saying YouTube boxes
because realistically we're Fighters now
we're getting in the ring you've got
your own League essentially you know
just because you're not top of the world
Pro yeah I mean how many pro shows are
made up of lower level guys yeah that's
true yeah yeah you're gonna be in there
with the greatest literally so I'm gonna
go in there
because you know going back to what you
said about confidence how I'm going to
lose confidence I've got nothing but
confidence to gain really because I've
been in there with Floyd I'll I'll see
someone else I thought the best in the
world like what can you do yeah how can
you show me that I've not seen it
exactly yeah so I'm essentially treating
it like a
I'm gonna try and steal some things from
Floyd but when I'm fighting I'm gonna
steal some some tech yeah I download the
data yeah and and Canelo Alvarez a lot
of people have said his career was
greatly helped by his fight against
Floyd yeah because Floyd fought him when
he was very young and schooled him
really and then Canelo took so much from
that probably watched the fight back a
million times so you know you could do
the same just on the YouTube scene I
guess absolutely so I think that's a
great way of looking at it mate it shows
how humble you are and I like when I
watch the fight uh video that you made
saying I'm gonna share the ring yeah the
greatest it was very respectful and I
think um
you know Daley said in his video just
have fun exactly I mean you're getting
to do something that all of the people
around you who are training you I could
say daily in his video just like almost
like a little kid at Christmas like I'm
gonna get the warp my fighter to the
middle of the ring and go and let him
fight Floyd Mayweather like I could see
his mind was blown by that yeah like at
one point he says in the video or
something like uh
he says um yeah when when we get that
shoot if I uh Floyd Mayweather and he
goes that still sounds so weird
but yeah for people like Leon you're
you're bringing them the people who've
made you are now gonna also benefit from
that experience because they get to be
involved with the Floyd Mayweather fight
exactly that's the thing about you when
you got in the ring after the the fousey
fight sorry and we were interviewing you
yeah you wanted to talk about the people
who helped you yeah it wasn't all about
you yeah which is unusual for a fighter
you know a lot of them just want the
Starlight they want to
boast and all of that but you're very uh
you're a more thoughtful guy than people
give you credit for thank you no thank
you yeah I guess that comes back to your
family really it doesn't because you're
a big family man yeah so let's talk
about the the journey yeah because
obviously there was Jake Paul and then a
long Hiatus and the Jake Paul fight
really shocked a lot of people and it it
raised your stock because you bloodied
them up you gave him a good fight and
people were like Daddy is actually tough
to deji's actually not a silly little
kid like what we all kind of thought you
were because that's part of the
character
but then I felt like you undid a lot of
that against Vinnie Hatter and and then
Alex Wassabi as well my thing was the
Vinnie had no one what went wrong there
because you were so out of shape and you
were doing things in the ring which
would just you were just scratching your
head watching it I was so confused
with the
uh Jake Paul fight obviously I took like
a three-year Hiatus of like this
doing stuff but I wasn't enjoying what I
was doing like the content I was making
I was doing like reaction videos and
stuff and you seemed unhappy if I'm
honest yeah you were lashing out a lot
there was beef there oh god there was I
mean you know no no I don't mind talking
about it yeah but it's true exactly you
lushed out at me one point you laughed
out with me
like me and Kim were getting it KSI uh
Randolph like anyone who you knew you
just went for it and I was like this is
uh like you know me I can take a bit of
fun yeah but with other people like
there was a diss track where you said to
Randolph your wedding was [__] and I'm
gonna [__] your wife like a horse yeah
oh my God you're calling your brother
out for abortions it was wild but you
were you were the type of person at that
point people must around you you've been
like this guy you don't I don't even
want to be involved in him he's so toxic
exactly what was it like being that
person and why did you become that
person
that's a really good question so um
that whole
angry face angry face I think that was
me letting the internet get to me um so
now I don't look at comments or anything
this that whatever maybe sometimes I
look at Instagram DMS or something yeah
but I don't look at comments anymore
before back then I was looking at
comments I was saying like because you
know you'll see all the nice comments
and then that one hateful comments yeah
we're all the same yeah
so that one here for comment pisses you
off yeah ten nice ones make you happy
yeah so uh
so I was I was very unhappy because like
all the content I was making I
essentially in like my viewership
dropped everything was just going
downhill and I remember the the subs
were going down yeah exactly my Subs
were going down I was getting to you
yeah everything was getting to me
because I was kind of just like being oh
okay I'm kind of just fading away off
the internet and other creators were
making jokes at the time exactly you
became a bit of a meme happen to me
before it happens all of us like I
remember what seemed to spot it was
there was something on the sidemen thing
about what's dead and was dead these
channels yeah something it was a joke
and then
that just lit the fuse yeah literally
when I when I saw that because I was
kind of just I was kind of just doing my
own thing obviously yeah I was losing
subscribers all of that I was doing my
own thing but then when that when I saw
that I was like why why kick a dead
horse so then I'll so then I was like
okay
then I had because you had nothing to
lose in your head yeah I'm already
[__] struggling
so you went a Randolph Randolph and you
sidemen were involved and then JJ got it
dragged into it yeah that at the time a
lot of people thought that was for sure
what how much of that was shown how much
of that was genuine upset and it was it
was all real well for me anyway it was
it was all real like uh now I was using
that as a way to just kind of take my
anger on like things I mean creatively
it brought out some interesting things
from you one of my funniest memories is
me-in-law's sitting watching you and uh
there's a line on the video where you go
yeah he ran hiding
and we were like and Frank I guess he's
talking about there's a bit of a history
lesson no Ann Robinson oh yeah
I was like I mean if the Nazis are
chasing you definitely die and then and
then and then I realized in that
scenario yeah you're the Nazis and he's
had fungus but yeah it was it was a wild
time and uh it was kind of look for us
content creators are watching it unfold
we're not sure how much is real how much
has paid and it's a bit of fun yeah but
to know underneath all that you would
genuinely pretty law people probably
didn't realize that exactly you know as
well as so
I took the Jake so obviously people were
saying like oh deji did so well the Jake
fight this up whatever but I took a loss
as a loss so and I let that loss get to
me really yeah how bad are we talking
like how how often are you thinking
about something like that on a daily
weekly basis I'll be real I lost so I
was a very confident guy after that loss
I kind of just became sheltered really
honestly I just so you didn't go out as
much literally yeah right I took the
loss way harder than I essentially
should have if that makes sense yeah
because Jake was obviously a we didn't
realize at the time but Jake was legit
yeah in a very natural naturally good
boxer yeah so there was nothing to be
ashamed of really but for you
I mean can you kind of describe life
beforehand and life afterwards so I get
a more yeah accurate picture of how you
change I'll give you like a better
example like uh so obviously I didn't
take the fight seriously and I was being
essentially no no I was a clowned but I
was being
I'm not I don't say attacked either but
I was being told like see you could have
been Jake if you just put put the work
in kind of being like yeah you know
because a lot of people afterwards said
you could have beaten Jake yeah exactly
so
in a video
I mean there's it's multiple really yeah
it was multiple being like see this is
you should have done this you should
have done that this that blah blah blah
and then this is kind of a young guy
getting told I told you yeah
it doesn't sit well exactly so uh I I I
just let it get to me way harder so
before before this whole box of thing I
was just doing my thing I was just like
bubbly guy is that whatever yeah then I
was like oh screw it let me do this
boxing fight like the whole build up to
the boxing fight was fun as well I
didn't really take it that seriously but
obviously I was gonna [__] talk and
everything and your style was Rising
yeah so you were gaining more popularity
than ever exactly and it was Brothers
versus Brothers yeah
so I I see no I must admit when I look
back at you because I remember you
vividly beforehand yeah you changed so
much because it was it was quite dark
yeah and
when you came back and fought Vinnie it
was years later so now to talk about
that so um
I had a chat with Shane before the
Vinnie fight I had a chat like no press
conference or anything like I had a tap
machine
and uh even he he this is what he said
to me he was like I can't
but my friend's bad malview I can't like
say anything nice because
you're not really showing anything good
if that makes sense so he was just kind
of
saying like right now what you're doing
you're not enjoying it and it's obvious
like you can see that there's no
happiness there you're kind of forcing
you I'm forcing a character or something
and that's what he said to me and I was
and I was kind of just like taking aback
that he said that because we're the real
ones tell you right exactly you can't
argue yeah yeah so then I was like whoa
and then and then he said uh
and then he mentioned the boxing he
mentioned boxing being like wasn't you
why didn't you show people what you
really can do in the ring because I know
you can fight this that blah blah blah
and then um I was I was like whoa okay
and then uh the Vinnie hacker fight came
uh came around but obviously
obviously I took the piss again I uh why
did you take the piss why did I take the
piss so obviously the narrative is yeah
30 years lazy yes that is the narrative
it's true I I am lazy I'm gonna say I'm
lazy I'm not as lazy I used to be but
why were you Lucy because I was always
handed things quite easily if that makes
sense so like with the whole box of
thing I grasped it I grasped it right
like quickly and everything I mean if
adult himself said you were more
naturally gifted than uh JJ yeah
literally so and then with YouTube yeah
obviously being care size little brother
doesn't make life too hard yeah yeah so
uh exactly I I kind of essentially got
things given to me I I didn't I wouldn't
say I wanted it given to me because I
remember saying at the beginning of my
whole YouTube like thing with JJ and
everything
I I don't want it to I don't want to
just like be
I got everything from you if that makes
sense I wanted to kind of show that I
can do things myself as well but
obviously we did videos together people
were gonna subscribe yeah but you've got
a mega Star as your brother yeah it just
is the way it is and it'd be silly not
to enjoy that and he wants to help you
he's a big brother so I guess this
ironically just to skip back to Floyd
yeah does this feel like the official
moment you step out of your brother's
Shadow because I mean although you are
out of your brother's Shadow this is
undeniable now yeah
I mean does it feel that way or have you
not even thought about that yeah I
haven't really thought about that I'll
be real I've been I've just kind of
so the food
it felt like that moment the best moment
on that show thank you and I I you can
hear it in my voice when you watch the
comments yeah believe it okay I've got
goosebumps now just thinking about it
because it was such an emotional moment
that everyone in that audience was like
wow we finally did it and he looked
unbelievable but
you're fighting Floyd Mayweather yeah
without your brother involved there's
nothing to do with your brother this
time yeah and Floyd's chosen you you
know so anyone left sort of wondering oh
is that ksi's little brother or what
it's like no he's he's dead he's
fighting Floyd yeah that's it and that's
something that you should be very proud
of thank you yeah so I essentially like
going back to your question like why was
I lazy yeah I kind of got handed things
to me I never really had to I mean I did
put work in like like uh let's say like
20 14 15 16 YouTube time I was I was
uploading every day I was uh I was
enjoying myself and everything this that
whatever but that's when you could do
whatever the hell you wanted back on
YouTube yeah
um but yeah I get that's that kind of
stems to my laziness as well it's just
well you know your parents because
obviously they're a huge role yeah in
your life do they have a sort of
criticize that about you all the time
all the time yeah really they're saying
they're always saying you're lazy you're
lazy all the time and uh and it's part
of that's being a young lad as well yeah
young men find it hard to focus on one
thing more than two seconds because
there's [__] porn and computer games
you know what I mean uh so that's fair
and I think it's great that you
acknowledge that and I guess
a rock bottom moment honestly yes I I
100 believe so yeah I I was going in
there I mean you saw how I looked I
looked terrible I uh my game plan was
just to knock him out first round yeah I
did feel that way and uh just I mean you
did put it on him to be fair yeah you
were you were actually throwing a lot in
that first round
you know what I mean like it was ironic
because the Alex Wassabi fight you
you were fit as [__] but didn't throw
and I'm like what happened to Derek
chisora which I seen in the last five
weeks came out like a destroyer
um
go let's just get in into the Vinnie had
to fight a minute like if you could take
yourself back imagine those rounds first
round's over how tired were you to in
order to need to take that break and you
know everyone made a fun of them taking
the knee and all that but were you oh
yeah I was tired really yeah not halfway
through the second round I was like
jeez I I can't do it anymore really
literally I was kind of just forcing
myself at that point to just that's what
I was getting clipped yeah I was getting
clipped because the guy I mean really no
disrespect I wrote for a pretty boy you
can fight yeah but he ain't on your
level yeah and you let him win that
fight yeah and that must be like
[__] annoying because yeah of course
and and the weird bit about that whole
thing for me was when we when I remember
me and Lawrence watching the Vlog yeah
there was a vlog I can't remember who
uploaded a vlog but there was a vlog of
your training camp and I used that term
loosely and it was like
it looked like a stag dude with a fight
just throwing in there it looked like it
looked like hey let's go on holiday
should we have a fight yeah [__] it come
on it wasn't even dead it wasn't even
like you were training for a fight yeah
I don't know who those Lads were and
there's a lot of things been said and I
ain't even blaming them I don't know
what the [__] went on but I remember
your girlfriend at the time yeah was
less than complimentary of them yeah can
you shine a light on what the hell was
going on because just like they were all
there for the crack rather than
betraying you so so we uh we were in
Cancun
like uh yeah already already me saying
that it's like what's going on
so yeah we were in Cancun for uh
what do you call it because of the whole
covert thing we had to isolate isolate
yeah okay and then um
we didn't really train the training yeah
I don't know so I would train what are
your boxing coaches yes so the training
that I would only really do was uh so we
had a basketball court in the sun I
would just run the lengths that's what
I'll do so my main goal at the time was
I was weighing like 98 kg yeah you are
nowhere yeah
exactly so [__] hell I had to come
down to a minimum of like 93 like to be
okay and I was just running the lengths
only drinking green juice and like one
slice of pineapple who told you to do
this though oh Junior
um these guys were telling you okay this
is how we're gonna get the weight off
you yeah with pineapple wait no no so uh
they were they weren't really giving me
any advice on um food wise like no
disrespect to them or anything like you
know they could yeah but you know they
weren't really giving me any advice on
uh food why what I should be doing they
just they would just want me to lose the
weight by any means Yeah by any means so
then what I would do I would just all I
did was have green juice
I had two green juice a day and a slice
of pineapple
so you can imagine I was drained for
that fight or in itself yeah
literally so
yeah what about the boxing side of it
were they training you oh no so I was uh
I was doing patch with them every now
and then but that's it every now and
then yeah yeah I know it's [__] sex bro
it's it's really bad I mean sometimes
you have to hit rock bottom before you
can actually make your way back up
though yeah and that is the only
positive I assume you take from that
whole experience is like never again
yeah you know because I remember JJ made
a scathing video after that because he
was just frustrated what was it like in
the aftermath when obviously we we you
probably felt like the Jake Paul moment
felt like a low but that that probably
wasn't as bad as what the Vinnie hacker
fight felt what was it like living
through the memes and the jokes and all
the [__] now this is gonna kind of
surprise you so after that loss after
the Gigi's video and everything I was
kind of like okay
that I actually just carried on just
making videos when you say okay what
does that mean when I say okay like uh
all right we move on I don't care so
because because there's two kinds of I
don't care okay and personally in my
life anyway yeah for me sometimes I'm
like oh all right I can live with that
it's fine all those initially that yeah
that one that one yeah because sometimes
I'm like okay fine but internally I'm
like [__] you guys yeah no no I was like
okay I'll live with that whatever yeah
whatever wow yeah I felt like I feel
like that's some sort of
a lot of respect for you yeah you didn't
respect yourself enough honestly at that
point your opinion of yourself yeah
I don't want to say depression but it's
not that far away from feeling depressed
that isn't it when you're just the
self-worth isn't quite there because
that guy who was flying at the start of
his YouTube journey is almost a memory
you know what I've actually never
admitted this to it uh anytime but so ah
this is mad so
um
I used to cry myself to sleep a lot um
during those times I'm not surprised I
used to cry myself to sleep a lot just
being like
I
I'm just like a failure you know what I
mean just like like what's my actual
purpose yeah I get that and you know
what the weirdest thing for creators
boys is like we put so much pressure on
ourselves to be always at the top of our
game exactly that if you're not in a
good moment and I know me personally if
I haven't just done a good podcast
recently or I'm struggling to get the
the Mojo I feel like a failure you know
so I can empathize with that it's quite
a normal thing and you are you're an
emotional guy more emotional than you
know you're either laughing your head
off oh yeah we you know we see that from
you and I think that's why people
connect with you so there's no shame in
admitting that yeah
uh if anything it's good to hear that
someone who has got insane success in
his life 10 million plus Subs all of the
things you've done you've just been on
one of the best shows in boxing this
year but you're just a [__] person
yeah and um
was there anyone you told about that at
the time when it was happening no no one
what about you've had girlfriends and
stuff not nothing to them wow men bottle
[__] up don't we [__] me we really do
yeah no honestly I was just that was
just like a me moment oh you know what
even uh
I was even doing some stupid stuff like
uh
I would I will be spending stupid
amounts of money just to kind of cope
for things it was like yeah you were
releasing it through yeah and what about
like getting pissed or getting drunk or
whatever anything like that no no no no
thankfully you know that would have been
bad yeah but but you know you're eating
habits you're spending yeah yeah
honestly wow yeah yeah that's pretty bad
bro
um but that's the thing like no one knew
this yeah so I just kept it to myself
and then uh it feels like towards the
Alex Wassabi fight something
changed maybe yeah did you go you
weren't you you were in much better
shape for that fight you're in a better
Direction
what what was the turning point was
there a turning point or not no there
was a turning point so uh I got myself a
PT Kyle Kyle Sullivan okay uh because I
told him uh help me
help me help you
yeah so uh yeah he helped me uh lose
like a a lot I don't even really give
him that much credit but yeah thank you
Carl Sullivan like you've done a lot for
me so um
yeah so he kind of he was like the
Pre-Workout and then I had my camp with
uh
um
see that that one was that was a weird
one too because uh I had coaches and
then like halfway through then I went to
daily that was weird right yeah why do
why the change but because yeah so the
change I don't I don't feel like I was
being pushed enough if that makes sense
so um and the guy did a video about that
oh God I mean that's the problem when
you become a YouTuber is like you're
you're an opportunity for anyone
everyone and you know we know this is
like you can't have a [__] friendship
yeah without someone making a video or
whatever but um
what you know you had every right to
change what was it like when you seen
that video come out where the guy who
was training you was like don't do this
I didn't want to do that or I didn't
watch it I mean I already knew it was
going to be about I didn't waste my time
I was just yeah I'm the same when
someone makes a disc video about me I'm
bitching about me I'm like I don't need
that negativity that's cool you're one
of many I was on the library you [__]
yeah
um so okay so you made the right call
obviously daily when I was after the
Alex of Sabi fight when that video came
out oh yeah so um this is where Shane
come like fully fully comes in and he's
like you want you want to shut this
video up win your next fight
um and he was like okay cool right so he
used that as motivation yeah coming into
the Alex Wassabi fight you're obviously
in better shape yeah a lot of pressure
on didn't really pull the trigger on the
night and I I remember I was watching it
I was watching it right that computer
there and I was I was pissed off because
I could see that you had the skills to
compete with him and at the end I was
like [__] [__] like I was I was
genuinely frustrated you know what I
mean and I I guess some people may have
been the same around you afterwards
because I felt like you didn't learn the
lesson at that time obviously later you
obviously did but you were like oh I did
great everything was great and then JJ
and many other people were like but he
didn't fight like you didn't pull the
trigger what was it like realizing all
of that after the fight there's a
there's a theme with uh my first three
fights my mentor was not like right if
that makes sense so for the Jake fight I
was coming in there being like oh wow
this is actually happening no way I was
kind of just fine off instinct
second fight
I didn't my brain wasn't there I wasn't
even thinking like I If you I couldn't
even remember what was going on it was
it was very weird wow and then with this
third fight
I uh uh I don't think I've admitted this
either so before it
the guns were sorry yeah I um I called
my mum and I'll just bursted into tears
and the thing is the reason why I
bursted into tears is because I I kind
of just knew
no like it wasn't right like um
there's there's a lot with the fousey
fight that I need to mention as well
because uh before that fight as well I'm
skipping a bit I know I'm sorry
um before uh the fousey fight JJ called
me
and uh he said one thing that just
relaxed me throughout the whole day okay
he said you've got nothing to lose let's
go in there have fun that's all he said
and I was like well because he's yeah
he's he's massive in your life obviously
and he's put pressure on you in the past
yeah but in that one call he took the
pressure away literally nobody else
could literally because this was his
show hmm he said it and I was like whoa
no but the thing is during the whole a
fight week of the fousey thing I was
like yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna go through
this guy I was just like yeah I could
see that yeah your whole vibe was
different you were so much more mature
but going back to the Wasabi fight yeah
because we are dancing around the call
with your mother yeah
can you remember what you said to her
and what she said to you yeah
I called her
[Music]
um
I was like I can't do this
and she said I can't do this I was just
crying on the phone I can't do this and
then and she started crying back too
because I was crying and then
obviously my mom's religious she started
praying for me and then um this is this
is the weird one while she's praying
I'll Shadow Boxing just to kind of like
psych myself
yeah user yeah cool myself down and sort
of psych myself up being like you can do
this come on deji and every and
everything and then
essentially it did help
but then when it comes to my ring walk
of the Alex Wassabi do you know that
feeling when you can just cry and I got
that feeling again I was like
I was like whoa like
what am I doing there
um
I didn't want to be here
literally
you know Pro Fighters have said those
same things or Donald Cerrone who fought
Conor McGregor in that fight a couple of
years back he said I got in the cage I
just didn't want to be there yeah so
it's normal this is a guy who's got
probably more UFC fights than anyone
else feeling the same way you were in a
fight against Alex Wassabi a YouTube guy
so you know I think it's important not
to beat yourself up too much about those
moments yeah but it does feel like the
lack of preparation has been a key
reason why in the back of your mind
there's always that doubt of like have I
done enough whereas it felt like the
fousey week so calm I was there watching
you guys talk it's enthusi fuzzi is very
uh full-on you know and I can imagine a
little bit intimidating for people who
are about to fight him when he's got
that look in his eyes and he is like you
[__] up picking me and he's there with
his washboard abs like acting like I'm
I'm ready for you you know he's ready as
in fight ready
but you were just like okay it was a
total different vibe I was like wow deji
like
feel so much more grown up the way you
were talking to people it was like you
matured a lot
why the change in Attitude energy
maturity that's what losses do honestly
like uh I was just losing all the time
so
I'll be honest like before the Jake Paul
fight I was a very up my ass type guy I
was like I'm the [__] look at me is that
whatever those three losses really like
brought me down to Earth being like what
are you doing like wow this that
whatever and I'm honestly I'm happy for
those losses I needed those losses
because we have that in life don't we
it's not just in the ring but like yeah
something's being humbled it's painful
but it's [__] necessary to give you a
better version of you because I mean I
was a [__] let's be real we've all
been there
so because the people who actually cared
about me I kind of just threw them away
really I remember I went through uh a
whole a whole period like uh going back
to the whole like you know after the
Jake Paul fight I was just unfollowing
people and then when you said something
bad about me even if they're joking I
was unfollowed them I couldn't take a
joke everything would pissed me off
because yeah control of you whereas the
dead Jew before fousey yeah the eagle
wasn't there because when he's going at
you you didn't even feel the need to
respond you were like it's all good like
a total different attitude there's one
Tick Tock that I saw JJ react I didn't
even know I did this so he because he's
saying oh I'm gonna [__] you up this
that blah blah blah and then it turns to
me and I just smile
I didn't even know it like yeah
so so what was the you've talked a lot
about your ring walks and how you're
feeling on them yeah
what was the feeling because the fousey
fight was different in that yeah
biggest YouTube boxing event ever
and yet you seem calmer what was the
feeling on the weight of the ring so
throughout the whole fight because calm
yeah you know this and then um that ring
walk
I loved it oh I loved it so song
selection is actually a key a key part
of uh like the whole thing I picked last
loss by Burna Boy
I was just vibing I've been I always
listen to that song Thank You Ryan again
he's the one who actually introduced me
to vulnerable so I think it's healthy to
have a song that relaxes you on the way
exactly some people get too geed up by
their music and they're [__]
adrenaline's pumping exactly yeah so I
felt like Gibb did that on his fight
with Jake Paul he was so pumped on the
way it was like mate you gotta save some
energy for the ring yeah so I was just I
was just relaxed what was it like when
you were in there with him and you
eventually started Landing those shots
like when you see in the fight unfolding
and you at what moment did you feel like
I've got you you're you're [__] now
all right I'm gonna be super honest I
don't remember really I don't remember
the fight oh I was so zoned in honestly
yeah I was so zoned in so what what what
is your last memory and first memory
like last memory before and first memory
after like can you what was the bits
that you do remember of anything so I
remember I I couldn't hear the crowd
really couldn't hear anything that crowd
was
wow you had the loudest scream of the
Night by a mile yeah not even close I
didn't even hear them yeah I heard them
after the win well I saw I saw the
towers like whoa what and then I was
like wait
yeah
the fact that you're even up then like
you were
still as mad because you were the you're
so confident in that essentially
everything I've been training like it
just came in literally finally yeah all
put together the fitness the technique
it was every weakness that we'd seen
from you was was gone like all the big
weaknesses that meant that you would
fall down at some point were gone but
kind of
so like uh halfway through my camp like
not the bad half the good house
I kind of programmed my brain in the
sense that the moment I hit the ring
just whoever's in front of you just
fight them so literally I'm anytime I
just hit the ring I'm zoned in yeah all
the thinking there's a big problem in
sport is that a new seem to have just
like
found a way around that to be to to be
in there and be feeling it not
overthinking it I owe that to uh the
mental side to Leon and chain honestly
if it wasn't for them I I'm telling you
right now I would not want my fight and
I know that for a fact I want to talk
about JJ
obviously a huge part of your life yeah
but it's been an up and down
relationship that's played out in front
of everyone what is the relationship
like now after all of those ups and
downs
I mean before I was kind of scared to
talk to him now I don't mind I could
scared why
I was scared in the sense that I know
I've kind of disappointed him I know
I've done so much bad stuff to him like
he literally has no reason to talk to me
like the whole public thing that we had
should not have been public it shouldn't
have I I was like an extremist you were
uncontrollable yeah
it's kind of like yeah like you were
kind of bipolar like very hard yeah
pinned down and he was trying to
regulate a situation exactly and you
were like no don't control me yeah
literally must have been very
frustrating for him but that's that was
me letting the internet get to me again
like
internet is uh they [__] with you yeah
literally I actually said to a friend of
mine the other day don't get me wrong
thank God I'm in the business I'm in
because my job beforehand was a lot
harder you know on the body and
everything else but
[__] mentally I don't know if there's
a worse job for your mental health in
the UK than being a YouTuber who gets
told on a daily basis he has why you're
[__] [__] and he has what we hate
about you yeah you know people worry
about footballers and and then playing
the game it's like we're critiquing the
game whether critique of boxer skills
yeah but you we get it about us
personally yeah you're a dick because of
this or that oh you look fat
yeah it is pretty rough and and
unfortunately that probably had you all
in a bad State yeah for a good
relationship with your big bro who
what was there ever I don't know
jealousy or inferiority feelings or did
you ever get annoyed that people seen
you as in his shadow or was that ever
the driving force behind the issues or
so I was I was never jealous but I was
pissed off that my efforts of being
overshadowed and that made sense yeah
like you didn't want to take away his
success yeah exactly but you just wanted
to be recognized yeah literally so
because I I was doing my own thing but
then people would well I mean people
still do it now they compare I don't
like so again before the Jake Paul I had
really light thick skin
my skin kind of just
kind of just like what you're all my
wedding yeah literally and then um
yeah and now I'm Me growing up my people
say whatever I'm just like okay what
kind of things you talk about with JJ
everything really really literally
everything so um I think the last thing
I talked to him about was uh so my
friend Shane is an awesome supporter and
then I was like I wanna can you get me
tickets to uh the Derby oh dude that's
cool yeah so I I don't know literally
that's what I did for saying I was
dropping tickets and he's guests so
that's that's lovely man and obviously
look your uh your big Christmas Fallout
was biblical yeah it was such a weird
time on YouTube to see two guys who um
mega popular going at each other on
Christmas but what was going through
your head towards him because it felt
like
Bridges were burnt at that point so I I
had just come back from La obviously I
did that stupid diss track what I did on
him it was probably a best truck to be
first I think JJ said that himself he
was like it would be the good one
against me wouldn't it yeah you know
yeah so we're not really enlisted like
guys he had beef with like was it yeah
juxton Crypt yeah and Jello as well yeah
so uh yeah I um did that
not super diss track and uh what was the
thing in that moment of doing that diss
track what why why why why why take it
to another level I was just angry oh I
was I was just there were a lot of
things run out like I've kind of erased
a lot of it from my head but I was it
was just pure anger just pure just anger
he just is oh
yeah why why him why why angry with him
specifically so um there was one
so there was aspiring footage that I had
with JJ and then I saw that and then it
was just between me and JJ but then I
saw that sparring footage in Randolph's
District
so then I was like oh so
you so what was my thought process was
oh okay so
you uh you've given Randolph exactly
you've given him some ammunition this
that blah blah blah so you told him this
that blah blah blah and that was going
through my head so instead of going at
Randolph
and that's when the whole thing what was
that like for your parents over that
period you think oh God
it was it was bad man it was really
really bad especially because we were
going through the um
the whole dog situation as well oh yeah
yeah I remember that you were pretty low
about that as well because you're for
those who don't know um you had a dog
like you absolutely loved cold tongue
yeah had an incident
and someone was pressing charges yeah
and literally so we my mom was going
through that and my dad as well but
obviously my mum was getting most of the
uh
the uh what do you call it back glass
okay well from the police and everything
really so uh we were going through that
um then there uh everything was
so my parents
by my mum she she was
I I'm to my dad he's he's very uh Macho
he doesn't he never show emotions but
obviously I knew he was feeling it
because when we had our court
um the court case and everything I I've
never seen him cry really and I saw him
cry there what was it that made him cry
uh when um
when I go out when it was like told that
our dog was gonna get put down um
my dad I'm I I've I was angry
and then two horses so but all I could
do was just I held both their hands and
I was like it's all right I had to stay
strong myself they'll put it for crying
and I was staying strong during the
whole
um the whole thing can you run like
Masters to actually what that incident
entailed my neighbor
um they were on our grounds my dog
charged at her and um
she hit tank over the head and then
obviously tank retaliated by nipping her
and then uh but it wasn't a bad bite it
wasn't a bad bite no and then um
yeah I mean I guess because you had a
big dog it's like exactly the little
[__] who does that knowing about an
island yeah a big dog people instantly
freak out and then um the the police
they actually uploaded the the footage
yeah but then people were they were like
what's wrong with this yeah because yeah
I remember the footage because even I
seen it she was like out the gate
exactly yeah and it's like well what are
you doing yeah and then uh they were
getting so much backflow so they ended
up the least yeah yeah because
maybe they're the least spot in the year
yeah so um obviously we will go through
all of that and then um this whole
genius situation me and my parents
especially my mum she was uh she was
down like really really down in like
destroyed everything was just
did you
I don't know did you feel partly
responsible for that
in terms of everything that she was
going through of course 100 like uh
if I could turn the clock back there's a
lot there's a lot I would change have
you guys talked about this open layers
and like
as a family or are you more the type of
family to just try and get on with life
and not dwell on those things so I've
apologized to my my parents I've wanted
us to JJ regarding the whole situation
and everything so um
yeah we're kind of the type to just
what's happened move on you know what I
mean I think that's healthy you know I
mean there's no point in yeah and with
with JJ in your relationship obviously
he's gone on and probably achieved
things that nobody thought possible at
this time of this music and it's
fighting and everything
what's it been like for you to watch the
kid who you remember you know as a
little geek playing FIFA
happy to see him transform and do all
this I'm not happy for it yeah like
seeing
him do his thing is just amazing because
I remember back back when we were in our
older
the first house yeah seeing him do his
wraps and everything I would love it I
would be like okay yeah and now see him
on the big stage is amazing oh yeah and
when I got to see him perform um in the
O2 was it the O2
Wembley um
I was blown away I was like
from being at his desk to this it was it
was amazing you know what I was more
looking at one of his dances though yeah
he's not the only one
yeah I mean but you know the real him
more than any of us you know you know
the the kid inside in terms of how he's
changed I mean success changes everyone
how would you say he's changed from the
kid who you knew to the man he is today
so so what are the main differences
obviously he went through his ups and
downs as well like um obviously I'm not
gonna talk about them because I I doubt
he would want me to yeah people know but
like uh he went through a lot um and it
kind of just shows that if you get if
you were being at the top
there's there's always like you
obviously you have to kind of put up a
front but at the same time there's a lot
going on that people don't know so it
could be quite Lonely at the Top exactly
and uh I saw that with JJ there were
times where I could see that he was just
lashing out and I would just be like let
me just spend time with you it was one
time I just I literally just came to his
house to talk then I feel like that made
us even closer honestly after that we've
been nothing but I don't I don't mind
saying anything to him that makes sense
it's important to have that as as guys
in it like because there's times where
you bottle things up and then I I know I
push people away and I isolate when I'm
feeling the pressure of life and all
that [__] but the minute someone who you
know has got your back Sit Stay in front
of you yeah in person not on the phone
or whatever but ideally in person like
you say in the room you will open up and
uh he knows he's got you for life in
that regard so do you ever worry about
them though in terms of like
unfortunately the shitty side of the
industry is you've got so many people
who will look at JJ as an opportunity
exactly a cash cow yeah and he is like
you know that's what happens when you
make shitloads of money you need a team
that's part of life but do you ever
worry about
people capitalizing and using him and I
mean I've told I've talked to JJ about
this I've told him there are some people
that you know just be wary and all that
and everything so he knows all that and
I never do name them have you said like
watch that one maybe
yeah yeah so um and then I've also
there was one point where he would uh
see me that way too he'll be like you
just want to use me to grow wow and I
was like I'd never won that I don't want
you to feel that way because um with
this whole believe it or not actually JJ
is the one who uh is making me upload
again really yeah because I I like
neglected YouTube I was just kind of
just doing this whole just focusing on
books so he never has throughout all of
this yeah always stayed consistent yeah
so um
literally he he was the one being like
you need to upload again you're
neglecting YouTube I know you love
boxing this that whatever but you need
to start uploading again this that
whatever so yeah yeah he's helping me
upload it again yeah and so when he said
oh you're just sort of using me yeah and
like look we don't know what frame of
mind he was in at that moment and I can
only imagine how hard it must be I know
from my experience in life the amount of
people I've [__] given stuff to and
you [__] me over is it I can't only
imagine what it's like but yeah so you
know if he was a little paranoid who
would blame him but
um yeah was there a were you feeling
kind of like wow I can't believe you'd
see me that way because that's not yeah
it's in here yeah so like uh obviously
when um
I heard that I was kind of I went to the
net kind of show him that that's not the
case so then I wouldn't
kind of keep my distance and show him
that
I don't want you to see me that way if
that makes sense yeah and is that the
right way to go back exactly yeah so
then you [__] you though yeah
literally so uh
me keeping my distance made things worse
really because then he was like okay
what you think you're better than me
this I probably is
yeah so um
I mean that's the thing we were both
growing up like in the spotlight exactly
[__] hard man yeah it is and look you
know we've seen Jake and Logan have
struggled with the same exactly it's not
easy so uh that's the thing like uh
unfortunately
a lot of our stuff was public but yeah
it was uh
it was one of those we went through it
it was um we were both growing up
and yeah you've gone through the
deji little Eagle Mania right gone
through the the beatons you took them
like a man you learn from them you came
back stronger and now you're bigger than
you ever were but now you've got the
life experience to use and go don't get
carried away this time because I know
how much I can [__] it up what are the
the things you're worried about now as
as you approach like the Prime deji oh
yeah
what am I worried about now
um I get I'll probably say
girls now oh man
are you seeing anyone now no I'm single
okay yeah girlfriend
who was very public very outspoken yeah
what very volatile very okay so what
what went wrong with that that
relationship
um
I'm a very ambitious person okay and I
want someone to match my ambition if
that makes sense I don't want someone I
can never just
settle I always want more if that if
that makes sense well what just more
success for yourself yeah exactly and
you want someone who also is ambitious
in their own life exactly okay but so
you don't want someone who's just gonna
back you and be there for you you want
them to be getting their own goals so I
wonder so they can back me as well as be
ambitious you know yeah exactly like you
said have their own goals as well not
just
just what they have and a lot of women I
don't know you're a meal ticket now
let's be real
it's going to be difficult to find
someone but when you say ambitious
ambition can come in a lot of forms you
can have someone who is uh pursuing a
career in in working in hospitals or
anything do you mean any kind of
ambition or do you do you think that you
want someone who's more aligned with
because I spoke to Logan and he said he
wants a woman who understands the
industry does that matter you or not I
wouldn't say so no not really she's got
a normal person essentially honestly
yeah
I think I'd prefer that if anything
because uh
I feel like
there were times where it was getting a
bit competitive between you and her yeah
and I I kind of saw that as in she was
very ambitious herself but too ambitious
no I wouldn't say she was too ambitious
she was more oh what's the best way of
putting it she's regarding the Limelight
no she okay no yeah thank you she was
seeing me do things and then she would
copy it if that makes sense so let's see
if I don't upload for a week then she
would be like oh I didn't have to upload
for a week if that makes sense all right
so she was just paying attention yeah a
lot of what you were doing and then as
well as when I go back to the whole
ambition thing
like uh so she was a YouTuber before you
I didn't realize that no no she wasn't
no she just started yeah yeah exactly
wow so uh she
ever really do anything outlandish if
that makes sense so you wouldn't really
want to put the effort in if that makes
he wasn't damn I really sucker explain
it
let me ask because I'm here to ask the
question so you meet this girl yes
she starts a YouTube channel after
meeting you yeah now historically
that goes very well for the girl yeah
and at some point you know she doesn't
need you anymore was that ever in your
no no no thought process I always wanted
her to go beyond me really if that makes
sense like Not Just Do Your Own Thing
yeah exactly I wanted to do our own
thing but she was always okay to just
settle like let's say she had like a
brand deal she'll do the brand deal and
then the money she got she'll just chill
she'll be like cool I've I've got money
I can now just relax whereas I'm with
someone who's they get that money they
tasted that oh I want more now more more
it's not running no because you've been
accused of being lazy and that's
something that you find quite
unattractive in someone yeah okay so
let's talk about uh physically what do
you like in a woman is there any things
that y'all
I'm actually a very easy person honestly
I've uh I've been my girls taller than
me because shorter than me saying hi I
actually don't mind honestly what about
physically is there a is there a thing
that you look for because you know you
got guys who are bum guys yeah guys yeah
I'm definitely a bum guy 100 so yeah I'm
at 100 bum guy and uh and let's talk
about like as they say green flags that
you look for as a person yeah you type
so you've said you like someone who's
driven yeah motivated yeah what about
how they treat you specifically
so obviously I don't want them to
be like Starstruck I wanted to just kind
of be more chill and just be cool with
me be comfortable with me if that makes
sense and I'll be comfortable with you
yeah about the whole YouTube thing which
is probably why I think a lot of guys
out there who are in the industry like
quote-unquote normal women with normal
jobs is because it's like
you don't want to be in that mode of
YouTube all the time you need to switch
off right exactly and they they take you
out of that
so yeah yeah and then as well as I I
don't know I feel like it's more
beneficial because
don't get me wrong uh with YouTube
having a public relationship with like
another like influencer is
I've seen it it doesn't it never ends
well yeah JJ's avoided that as well yeah
yeah I I think the smart smart people do
that to be fair unless unless you're
absolutely sure this is yeah
it's a rough one because when you break
up you have to do the breakup yeah
sure
uh what was your longest relationship
that one I really I've only ever had one
relationship and that was uh how long
was it two and a half years wow yeah was
it weird when when it was no more and
you kind of you're sitting there and
you're like oh man I'm watching Netflix
with now then I'm on my own or oh what
did it was it was it a relief how did
you feel it no oh like uh I feel like it
was best for both of us really really I
was I was more relieved I'm pretty sure
she was relieved too because uh I don't
think she liked the whole
in the spotlight thing so I thought I
mean she was following you down to the
boxing with a photo and I was like this
is wild I don't know what's going on
yeah yeah it must have been a lot for
you guys to go through in that I know
that was um that was the coach's phone
she was they they said record it that is
mud because she hammered those guys
didn't she yeah yeah something that was
funny bringing it right the way back to
Floyd
this is
I guess going to be one of the biggest
moments of your life yeah it's
Monumental really yeah yeah are you
going to be able to do the thing that
you do
in the ring with Floyd which is switch
off and do your normal thing or do you
think that the fact that his eyes are
going to be on you and you're going to
be painfully aware that he is the goat
or one of do you think that will impact
you more
when we do our face off I'll DM you and
I'll tell you I appreciate that yeah
I'll tell you yeah I'm [__] myself
yeah get me out of this pull me out
coach uh you'll be fine you've got Leon
behind you thank you we'll tuck him in
halfway through just let him take over
um one last question for you dadge 100
and I've thoroughly enjoyed your day
thank you is um how would you like to be
remembered how would I like to be
remembered
I'll probably say I'd like to be
remembered as Tony would never give up
as much as people you know would [__] on
him this that whatever he never gave up
you know what I was hoping you'd say
that because that's how I see you uh so
respect you proved me wrong time and
time again now and uh we're all gonna be
rooting for you and uh a win is stepping
in the Ross with one of the greatest so
well done for you mate thank you that
was deji on the true Geordie podcast
don't forget to subscribe like the video
and we'll see us on the next one come on
deji come on
thank you that was good